una de las masacres más mortíferas en la
historia reciente de Serbia en Belgrado
la capital un adolescente abrió fuego en
un colegio contra sus compañeros de
clase el asalto fue premeditado y lo
llevó a cabo con el arma de su padre
el niño según el mismo dijo planeaba
realizar este acto contaba con una lista
de los niños que planeaba liquidar
el mismo dibujo los planos de la entrada
y salida de la escuela se encontraron en
su escritorio
el atacante disparó primero contra un
guardia de seguridad luego en un pasillo
accionó su arma contra tres niñas
finalmente agredió a los asistentes a
una clase de historia como mi segunda
clase estaba en el último piso estaba
subiendo mientras lo hacía pude escuchar
un sonido y pensé que tal vez eran unos
niños tirando petardos y que se estaban
divirtiendo pero luego pudo Escuchar más
cerca y el sonido venía del frente de la
escuela vi como un guardia caía al suelo
Así que rápidamente corrí hacia donde
estaba el autor de los hechos cursaba
séptimo grado y fue detenido tras la
masacre los padres de los menores
acudieron a la escuela en busca de
información al principio pensé que había
muerto un niño y luego descubrimos que
eran más en años anteriores servía
experimentó hechos similares entre otros
casos en el año 2013 un ciudadano
asesinó a 13 personas en el pueblo de
velica y banca en el centro del país
mientras que en 2015 un hombre mató a
seis invitados a la boda de su hijo en
la localidad de